I want to try to get through this video
without saying the word penis hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to the balloon animal
challenge I'm joined once again by
witness and bigness over here say hi
guys hey hi so we're back with the
balloon animal challenge we've got more
balloons here and we've got more
suggestions from again notice how I
stopped holding oh I just did he's going
way too smart so we're gonna be paying
more balloon animals but this time
instead of making your favorite animals
into balloon form we've got a list of
your least favorite handles so beware if
you have specific phobias of the animals
that you're not gonna meet you don't
know what you're gonna see starting with
one but here's the twist
look at that hey wow that's a helium
tank so you notice these are not filled
with helium they're not that's a lie I
can't believe you lie to your fans we're
gonna start the round with this one
balloon but every other balloon that
we're gonna need in this whole thing you
have to run back there grab one of the
balloons around the balloon pile and
make another balloon you throw those
puffs away
[Music]
anyway we're gonna be using the helium
tank to fill these up so in order to do
that we're gonna need a little more time
than we had before before we had one
minute or something like that some
arbitrary number that some [ __ ] like
changed in the last second but this time
we're gonna get two minutes to be able
to make these balloons into balloon
animals are you ready wingus yeah are
you ready dingus sure so let's go to
balloon what's her personal visit
Siegel's like multiple if you want okay
ready I'm ready
everyone visualize what you're gonna
make just visualize don't make it yet
okay are you ready three two one go
[Music]
what stop
[Music]
fire and the handoff hey now we have to
say for yourself mr. so what we have
here is an Atlantic seagull not here
native to the Los Angeles area
you can see the the bill on the Atlantic
seagull is very not quite as pronounced
as the Pacific seagulls that we all
commonly associate from the Hollywood
movies it's actually got large loping
ears to scoop air in through its ears
and then flap out of its broad very
broad wing ease here they're actually
like interesting thing about the
Atlantic seagull is that it has a rudder
it steers in the air carving like an
elegant gazelle of the sky not the rats
of the sky you swine
the Gazelle of the sky they're very
graceful creatures and of course these
are its trademark droppings shut up
kih-kih-kih-kih-kih caw caw caw caw caw
caw caw the Atlantic seagulls droppings
or white show us what you got snakes of
the head of the seagull with the beak
it's actually beautifully done if I do
say so myself
and this particular seagull got stuck in
a trash can of sorts a hand that was
left on the beach by us humans and
littering so it is forever duck and
entrapped and it's it's realistic
because that's the sad truth
are we gonna do with these balloons
after we're done all right well yours is
garbage so you make that so according to
our panel of judges here wait I'm gonna
leave let's leave it here it'll be like
a gallery well we'll leave the art here
and then we'll just hope that some art
critics will walk by and then judge them
must leave well respect the judges you
don't hey don't touch its proboscis jeez
that's the worst thing you've ever done
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay we got a new new one and we're
ready to go
this brings a whole busy one semester
original idea yeah okay and mine dance
like some like a ballerina No
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Tyler sure so as you know what the
Frog baby tiny little tail but nice
little like and this unfortunate frog
ran into an accident and his he was born
with his legs merged with his head his
front legs of mine is I call it the
journey of a life of a ball right okay
so let's start from the very beginning
of a frog's life the eggs chained many
eggs together all in a spawning strung
together vulnerable the pink fleshy
could be longer than five yeah
Oh sabotage I'd like to point out it was
very much explaining anything good
happen tragic it's tricky
art is tragedy okay Johnson it's trying
to be okay Shh okay so as you can see it
starts its life as a tadpole journeying
from the small egg growing until it
reaches to tackle status and then it
takes its first
crawling moments out from the water's
edge just like reminiscing the very
basis of life itself when we cross from
the ocean as just small fish e50 and
then when it gets on land
not born because it's already been born
but it's reborn as a frog here the giant
head staring at you here I
[Music]
there we have going back to the egg it's
in the goal it goes back blazing ANCA
the journey the cycle continues it's
everything that a frog is and more it's
all been a frog could be need i say more
judges thank you thank you would you
like to apply that frog that's that's
clearly a spy's even though I myself
would vote for that huh oh that would
have been a better way to go so even in
his absolute ignorance decided that he
was gonna be a dummy and not get a blue
and I mean I'm waiting to see what the
prompt
theory
I'm waiting guys look at mine I'm
waiting to see what the prompt is so I
can use correct and use the correct
color so the score is one for me one for
Ethan on nothing for Tyler yet this is
every possibility that he can redeem
himself
[Music]
[Applause]
My Mind's a long boy monkey and as you
know those baboons that have red asses
have some blue accidents hasn't learned
by the Lion King with those profound
lines up here that you got and then of
course he's got to have his legs and the
giant huge profound red buttocks
question did you read you can't there
was never a rule about that recycle
that's cheating with you use new
balloons that was that is or that is a
rule it was never set it was never said
aloud to put a if it was set aloud in
the last one then then the rules carry
over hi that's a gimmick all right we'll
leave it up to the final judges to make
the final decision I call this one
baboon in winter a tragic story if ever
there was one
there was no food did that fall didn't
have time to prepare left out foraging
on its own lost galloping through the
trees trying to make its way the snow
started creeping in the cold winds been
to the bone
clawing its way through a river see one
salmon still left not touched by bear oh
can it get close it's trying desperately
ah
frozen didn't make family starving back
home red but no frozen pool damn it
we're doing so good also you literally
all you have to do is explain what it
looks like you don't have to give a
Baxter look my order so much more to it
I was I will say one thing
god damn it I will say one thing monkeys
don't live yeah monkey stupid all right
well mine pretty basic to be honest
we've got the big the big head you know
they've got to use their dog in the next
next to humans monkeys are some of the
most smart species in the animal kingdom
he's got big big head eyes also got to
climb trees with and whatnot then you
know it we love it that big big the
flanks and the ass I was going for I
know we were talking about the big Brent
asked but I think that it's a little bit
more accurate that it would have a
pinkish hue because it's closer to the
skin tones of the apes and whatnot
that's pretty much my what's the blue
ah yes an elastic band - like a lobster
you gotta keep like a play get to work
it out it's like working out the glutes
you know those are elastic bands these
you know you know I see the kool-aid man
well see what you want to see artists
objective would like to point out that
[Applause]
[Music]
is also true longer why it's a leg thing
he's doing the same thing over and over
that can't count over and over again
well listen this one was specifically to
monkey with the red ass you've stolen
this from these families
well you didn't win my monkey one
obviously and I think everybody knows it
including yourself you're just too
afraid to admit what is the next prom
wait hang on let me show you guys so I
want to take the proboscis insert it
[Applause]
anyway what do you want a kind balloon
or a full boil
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's plan plans plan everybody
[Laughter]
explain yeah I'll go first
Tyler submits pose so what's the first
thing you think of when you think of a
kangaroo
[Music]
that's the first thing what's the second
thing you think of Lee you think of a
kangaroo right its ability to kick it's
got huge footers it's pretty busy
it's got crazy like a potential like
right okay so I wanted to start from
kind of like just feeling where the
balloon took me it's giving it's doing
that you know the emoji that goes you
know that emoji so it's doing a little
bit of that with this tongue like oh
yeah and then these are its ears because
it's the other thing that kangaroo is
known for its big ears it's got a big
snoot cuppa goos little sassy and grape
pickers yep I'll go next
so when I think of a kangaroo I
immediately think of the big old ears
big old it's just like a kind of like a
bunny rabbit but an Australian bunny
rabbit next thing I think of is that big
pouch the little babies go in obviously
this mother here hasn't had a child
quite yet but it's easy oh don't get too
pretty don't get don't do it so the big
pouch for the baby to go in the big ears
this one lost its legs and up
uncle accident so yeah that's my
kangaroo you take it into consideration
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] wait this looks like
something I made so Ethan won he has two
points I have one Tyler has one point
this is the parade of our creations not
in perfect harmony here but I think it's
good to end this one off with a little
bit of a song what should we sing
[Music]
doesn't appear okay
[Music]